last season ended with looks like the  end of the world Scully  it was on a bridge looking up towards  than a UFO  there was some kind of pandemic that was  sweeping the world Mulder was dying  it was quite unlike anything we'd ever  done before we're not used to struggling  looking at the UFOs and we're not used  to looking at Mulder at death's door so  those were the big questions that needed  to be answered and I think we have a  really interesting dramatic solution to  save humanity  you want to see blood in the streets it  is the war mr. Mulder my son is none of  your business  [Music]  I'm asking you to betray the whole human  race do you mind if I smoke  you